don't have an overall majority at this
stage
it's time fracture that the opposition
suffered up the nerve to submit
themselves
now in a few moments polling stations
across the united kingdom will close the
voting will be over and we'll be able to
reveal the result of our exit poll
that's our first hint of the possible
result so as big ben reaches 10 o'clock
we are standing by with those crucial
exit poll figures here they are
our exit poll is suggesting that there
will be a conservative
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
as you can see we've won before and now
we need to deliver a strategy to win a
game
nine years ago before i was a minister
and long before i became chairman i was
a 40-40 target seat mp
and in target seats like mine the 2015
general election wasn't about labour's
failures it wasn't about jeremy corbyn
or getting brexit done it was about our
local record of delivery
in just two years time our record of
delivery will once again be a deciding
factor in how people vote
so we need a massive effort to get our
local success stories out
to share the incredible things we've
achieved together as a party
and to let people know about the
important work that we're still doing
creating jobs investing in public
services and improving lives
and that's what the 80 20 target city
campaign is all about
this is a targeted focus campaign based
on the 80 marginal seats we need to hold
and the 20 marginal seats we have a
serious chance of gaining
we're going to need a huge effort from
everyone here today every single
activist every single member and every
single association
just like we had in 2015.
because the last two elections were
short and snappy
this campaign will take place over two
years just like the 2015 campaign
no one is saying it's going to be easy
but if we pull together i know from
personal experience what a difference it
can make
and i'm thrilled to say that we've
already hit the ground running we've got
new campaign managers across the country
helping mps tell their stories
the first leaflet of the 80 20 campaign
is hitting doorsteps this summer
and over the next two years there'll be
an opportunity for everyone here and at
home to play a role
whether that's sharing content on social
media or talking to voters and changing
minds
i'm confident if we come together put
that effort in and get our message out
we can win the next general election
in the meantime i hope you enjoy the
questions
we've got two excellent candidates and
they're both clearly ready to be prime
minister
but no matter which candidate you choose
let's remember that the country will be
making a choice two years from now
a labour government or a consular
government
so let's get to work
[Music]
from his parliamentary chains and
elected mark fletcher first ever
conservative to represent the
[Music]
we need to recruit new canvases new
deliveries new activists to spread
mark's message not just on the doorstep
on social media as well
that's on top of running local issues
campaigns such as here in blackwell with
the speaking campaign the a617 and
organizing community events is tough
work but it makes a huge difference and
none of it would be possible without
members like you and supporters like you
my position is funded entirely through
donations so every member donor and
supporter has the chance to play a
massive role because although it's my
job to grow the team here in balls over
campaign managers and successful
campaigns rely on people across the
country to support
but that's knocking on doors or chipping
in so i hope that over the next two
years 80 20 cannabis and mps like mark
fletcher will rely on you
[Music]
please welcome chairman of the party in
wales clinton davies
my first role is to
welcome you all to this to this
important event to thank you all for for
joining us
i'm very much hoping that you're all
going to enjoy the evening
in rishi and this
i know them both very well for my own
time in parliament
we have arizona states and which has
told us
two really excellent candidates either
of whom
will prove to be an excellent prime
minister
when they're when they become prime
minister on the 5th of september now i'm
looking forward to several weeks of
informative
intensive some type of debate
which on on september the 5th
will enable us all
to come together
as a team
a team committed to winning the next
general election
because that is
really the aim of all of us in this room
and as andrew said we need to get to
work to make sure that happens thank you
my final role is to hand over to uh
the chairman of the party convention
peter booth who's now going to come up
to take my place
[Applause]
good evening cardiff
this is the third in our national tour
of 12 hustings around the country and
it's the first outside of england
it's good to be here in wales
thank you all for attending this evening
and it's great to see so many friends
and colleagues in the audience
and thank you all of you for braving
extinction rebellion outside
these hustings offer us the members of
the conservative party
the opportunity to take part in a great
exercise of democracy
where we get to choose our new leader
will be announced on the 5th of
september and as with the party of
government
then will become prime minister very
soon after
as in dale who moderated many of these
hustings in 2019 said
and i quote
i found sharing the hustings a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces and asked
some very certain questions
so i asked of you all tonight
to make your questions searching
to make them succinct
and to ask questions and not to make
statements
one question each please so that more of
the audience get the opportunity to
question our candidates
both of our candidates have expressed a
duty and a desire to fulfill our 2019
manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about achieving that in a very
different world from 2019
post-brexit
post-covered
in uncertain times internationally as
we've seen today in taiwan and where our
union as a nation is being challenged
and that has particular relevance to you
here in wales
so i'm sure that you want to test our
candidates and seek to establish their
strengths
and to see who you think is best capable
of running our great nation
as we're all conservatives i know that
you'll be respectful of the two
candidates
and keep your questions positive
for them for me and for our cchq team
who have worked so diligently to set up
these hustings at short notice and in
mid-summer these hustlers run on a tight
schedule until our final rally in london
on the 31st of august
as you know our ballot is open the
ballot papers are in the post
you can cast your vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online or you can
choose traditional snail mail and if you
do post it then please remember to put a
stamp on your envelope
my hope is that this evening will give
you more clarity about how to cast your
vote
i hope that you'll go away enthused and
energized in your commitment to helping
our party at the next election
quite frankly we need your support
finally i want to thank you all in wales
for everything that you do for our party
it's much
appreciated and now let's get on with
the
[Applause]
show everyone can you hear me clearly
just checking the microphone's working
lovely to see you all and as a voice of
god otherwise known as tom has just said
my name's uh hannah vaughn jones and
some of you may remember me from just
three years ago it's certainly a bit of
deja vu for me to see some familiar
cases
back
however this time we have two different
candidates of course and it's the same
privilege and honor for me to be here
in your company tonight but also of
course to get to interview the next
prime minister and it is the same huge
responsibility for all of you
to pick the next prime minister on
behalf of the whole of the united
kingdom so i do hope that you will take
that very seriously when it comes to uh
considering your vote and also perhaps
considering your questions tonight make
sure that if you've heard something
already that's answered a question you
had in mind think of a different
question that would be great and time is
of course uh as ever of the essence now
the format you probably all know already
but essentially we will hear from the
first candidate who tonight will be
rushing sunak we will hear from rishi's
count first and he will do his uh pitch
to you as part of your leader
and then after that and his trust will
come on and she will do her
pitch as well following that then i will
get a chance to interview rishi and just
ask him a couple of questions of my own
and uh and then it's open to all of you
open to the floor
and then liz trust will come on
afterwards as well
for exactly the same so hopefully um we
won't be too late you know we had a bit
of a late start anyway and in the um
interest of saving time that i will stop
talking and we'll hand over to the first
speaker for rishi sumac
please welcome four million of the
conservative party lord michael howard
well good evening everyone
i'm delighted to be back in wales i was
born in boston went to school
internationally where i grew up
and it's always great to be
back i go back a long way
i've known
every leader of our great party
since harry macmillan
and our last three prime ministers
all served in my shadow team when i had
the honor of being the leader of our
great party
the greatest of all those leaders
was margaret thatcher
i knew margaret thatcher
i had the privilege
of serving in margaret thatcher's
cabinet
and i want to tell you one or two things
this evening
about margaret thatcher
she hated
inflation
so does rishi sunak
she hated the thought
of increased borrowing
so does rishi sooner
she would never have countenanced
unfunded
irresponsible tax cuts
nor
will richie sooner
and margaret thatcher always told the
truth
she didn't tell people
what she thought they wanted to hear
she told them the truth
and so
that's rishi sooner
now i want you to look forward a bit
to look forward
to the next general election
and to ask yourself the question because
in many ways it's the most impressive
important question of all isn't it
who's going to be best placed
to win that election who's going to be
best placed
to beat kia stammer the man who stood
side by side with jeremy corbyn who
tried to persuade us all three years ago
to make jeremy corbyn our prime minister
who's going to be best placed
to beat kiersten
and i ask you to consider this
we will only win that election
if as we approach it
in two years time
inflation is under control
borrowing is under control
interest rates are coming down and our
economy is back on the path to recovery
and rishi sunak is the only candidate
the only candidate whose policies can
deliver that outcome
we face many challenges in our country
but we're not alone
many other countries in the wider
western world
face similar
challenges but we have
alas
a leadership vacuum
across the western world
we have the opportunity
of electing a prime minister
who can provide the leadership we need
not only in this country
but across
the wider western world
the people of wales
especially welsh conservatives
are wise
we have good sense
we have good judgment
and that is why i am confident
that we will choose
to lead us
to inspire us
to take us to a great and glorious
future
our next prime minister
rishi sooner thank you
[Music]
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
i'm backing wishes tonight because he's
the only one who understands rural areas
like mine i'm the leader with serious
experience somebody can lead us through
the challenges ahead i want a leader who
will restore trust i am supporting rishi
sooner i'm supporting british sooner and
i'm backing
we're supporting rishi sooner
[Music]
please welcome rishi sumac
conservatives
yeah right well thank you all for doing
an incredible job taking our
conservative message to the people of
wales and gosh do you do it well so let
me start this evening by asking you to
join me in praising the incredible
leadership of the welsh conservatives
from andrew rt davis
it occurred to me this morning that uh
you know andrew arty davis obviously
took over from paul davis
and that was announced by glenn davis
who obviously took over from byron davis
which should get me thinking if i just
became rishi davis maybe i'll have the
edge here in wales
i'm standing here in front of you
tonight for one very simple reason and
that's because our country our united
kingdom did something extraordinary for
my family when it welcomed them here as
immigrants 60 years ago and allowed them
to build a better life
now i was raised with a few simple
values
firstly that family means everything to
me because the bonds of family are far
greater than anything
any government could ever hope to
replicate and we must never ever forget
that
now in my family
we prioritized hard work as the best way
to forge ahead
my dad was an nhs gp
my mom ran the local chemist in
southampton and i spent all my time
working in her shop and out and about
delivering medicines for elderly
patients who couldn't come in
i also did her books her accounts her
payroll every month and saw the power of
a small business like that to provide
jobs and opportunity in our local
community
and for my parents
the way that they thought they could
build a better future for their three
children was simple
and it was through
education
and i passionately believe that the best
way that you can reduce inequality in
society the best way that you can spread
opportunity indeed the best way that you
can transform lives is to ensure that
the birthright of every child is a
world-class education
something the welsh labor government
ought not to forget
[Applause]
patriotism service family hard work
aspiration and i'm sure looking out at
all of you that they are your values too
and that's because they are conservative
values and mine is an entirely
conservative story and that's why i want
to be your leader and next prime
minister to put those conservative
values into action to build a better
britain
just as this country allowed my family
to provide me with amazing opportunities
i want to do the same for everyone your
children and grandchildren and make sure
that they have the same amazing
opportunities too
so how are we going to do that well we
need to restore trust
we need to rebuild the economy
and we need to reunite the country
now restoring trust starts with honesty
and as you can see in this leadership
contest i have not taken the easy road
because i believe our country does face
some serious challenges and i want to be
straight with all of you and everyone
about what it's going to take to fix
those now even though that doesn't make
my life easy i believe it's honest and
that's what leadership is all about
but you also restore trust by delivering
on the things that you say that matter
to people and that's why i've set out a
bold plan
to properly reform the nhs
so that we can stop talking about how
much we put in and focus about the
health care that we're getting out
and whilst i'm doing that
i'm going to call out the fact that in
spite of receiving 20 more funding
here in wales waiting lists on the nhs
are the worst in the united kingdom and
that's why we need to kick out the
labour government and give the people of
wales the nhs that they deserve
[Applause]
we also need to restore the trust of our
rural communities to back farming to
back food security ensure that the
produce of welsh farmers is on kitchen
tables across the country and beyond
but we also need to tackle the issue of
illegal migration because for too long
we've watched on our tv screens the
scenes of illegal migrants coming in
small boats and that has to stop i've
set out a bold plan a radical plan and
under my leadership we will finally grip
that issue restore trust in the system
and take back control of our borders
now when it comes to rebuilding the
economy i don't need to tell all of you
what the number one challenge is you
know and that's inflation
and we've seen this story before we know
that inflation is the enemy that makes
everyone poorer it erodes people's
hard-earned savings and pensions
it pushes up mortgage rates
now of course i'm gonna help people with
the cost of living
that's what politicians should be
focused on right now not spending
millions of pounds increasing the number
of politicians in the welsh
[Applause]
senate so yes this autumn i will cut vat
on energy bills to help but what i'm not
going to do is pursue policies that risk
making the situation far worse and
last far longer
especially if those policies
amount to borrowing tens and tens of
billions of pounds
in unfunded promises putting it on the
country's credit card
and then asking our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab
because that's not right it's not
responsible and it is certainly not
conservative
now i am going to cut taxes and i've set
out a plan to radically cut the basic
rate of income tax by a fifth over time
because as a conservative government i
want to make sure that people's hard
work is always rewarded and they have
more money in their pockets but we are
going to do that responsibly we're going
to do it by being controlled with public
spending
and we're going to do it by growing the
economy and this autumn
i'm not going to stick with the failed
corporation tax policy of the past i'm
going to do something radical and
different and reform business taxation
cutting taxes on investment and
innovation so that we can get the jobs
and the growth and the productivity that
we need
i'm also going to invest in
infrastructure because that's how you
grow the economy
and we need to call out this other
labour policy of not building any more
roads for what it is an act of enormous
economic self-harm and the people of
wales deserve better
[Applause]
and in a post-brexit world we need to be
radical
as a backbench mp i came up with the
idea of freeports as a chancellor i
started to deliver them in england and
as prime minister i want to ensure that
we have not just one but two free ports
here in wales attracting jobs and
investment in the industries of the
future including hydrogen and of course
nuclear in north wales
[Applause]
because that's that's how you drive
growth in the 21st century economy my
experience means i am the best person to
lead our economy into the future and
seize those opportunities that are there
waiting for us if we're prepared to be
bold and ambitious
now when it comes to reuniting the
country
we have to do something that's never
been done before
we have to make british political
history in two years time
by winning
a fifth general election victory in a
row
now although that hasn't been done i am
confident that we can do it working
together
but it's going to mean that we have to
appeal to swing voters everywhere here
in wales
in scotland in the north in the south in
rural areas in urban areas in brexit
supporting areas in remain supporting
areas
and i passionately believe and all the
evidence supports it that i am the
candidate that offers our party the best
opportunity to win
everywhere and ensure that kierstarma
does not walk through the doors of
number 10 downing street at the end of
that election
[Applause]
and in conclusion let me just say this
you saw me as chancellor at the
beginning of the pandemic act boldly
radically ripping up the rulebook
competently
to protect millions of jobs across the
country to save businesses to ensure
that we kept our economy resilient
through one of the biggest shocks that
we had faced
and i promise you that as prime minister
i will apply that same urgency that same
energy that same grip and radicalism to
tackling all of our problems reforming
public services growing the economy
tackling migration putting in practice
those conservative values of hard work
of aspiration of hope that we all hold
dear to build a better britain
but more than that
i promise you all this
i will give you my everything my heart
and my soul everything i've got
to ensure that each and every one of you
here tonight
can always
feel enormously proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead
so i humbly ask for your support
not just to be
your next party leader
but also the next prime minister
of our great country thank you
thanks very much
[Applause]
right rishi sunak thank you very much
indeed and as i mentioned before of
course rishi will be back on to and take
some questions from me um but also take
some questions from you as well and that
you may have already heard some of these
opening speeches but they are obviously
then tailored to to you as well and you
heard a lot of mention of wales and and
what's the the pressing issues are in in
this country at the moment so hopefully
that's a lot of food for thought when it
comes to the q a and asking um your
hopefully very brief but very to the
point questions um with that we are now
going to hear from the other contender
contender
for the party leadership and for prime
minister of course let's hear from liz
truss's camp
please welcome mp for clewwood south
david jones
[Applause]
well
nos why tha gave atheon
good evening friends it's a great
pleasure to be here in such a in front
of such a large audience of welsh
conservatives uh welsh conservatives and
unionists
and tonight we're here to play our part
in the important selection process
for the next leader of the conservative
party
and the next prime minister
of our country the united kingdom of
which wales is such an important part
and it's my great pleasure this evening
to be here to introduce the person i
believe
to be the best qualified
to lead our country uh to lead our party
the excellent liz truss
because
i believe that liz is a person with a
strong record of delivery in government
and a clear vision for the future of our
country
she above all others
has seized the opportunities that brexit
presents
it was liz when she was international
trade secretary who pursued new free
trade deals around the world
deals worth billions of pounds to
british businesses
spreading prosperity right across our
country
and it is liz i believe who will spread
that prosperity
still further
she will for example create new
investment zones
including here in wales
she'll expand the shared prosperity fund
so she's so helping welsh communities
who have been so badly let down
by the
labor government here in cardiff
and by improving the important transport
links with the rest of the united
kingdom because liz understands that
wales is place within our union the
greatest union in the history of the
world
is all important
and under her leadership
it will continue to be the most
important union in the world
now as foreign secretary
liz has shown strong effective
leadership
she has supported president zieleski
zelinsky and the people of ukraine
against the aggression of vladimir putin
and the russians
she has given strong warnings of the
dangers of chinese communist expansion
and she has stressed and supported the
commonwealth
the largest group of free democracies in
the world
and as prime minister
she will ensure
that this country continues to pursue
its important world leadership role
so yes i do believe
that liz is the person with the big
picture vision
but she's also very much a down-to-earth
person
she understands the problems that
ordinary people including here in wales
are having just at the moment
with the cost of living which is a huge
worry for so many of us so many of our
friends so many of our neighbors
many people who simply don't know where
the money will come from to pay the next
gas or electricity bill
how they will be able to fill up their
cars to get to their place of work
these are real people with real problems
and the last thing that these people
need
is high taxes
so
liz is right to commit to cutting the
tax burden for ordinary people and for
businesses around this country
to help them through this difficult time
and to help build that future prosperity
to which she is so committed and i'm
sure
we'll be hearing a lot more from her
about that this evening
but i think you've heard enough from me
you came here this evening
to hear from the future leader of our
party and the future leader of our
country
so kavelion
obligated
the dana senedic ladies and gentlemen
please be prepared to welcome
the next leader of our conservative
party the next leader of our united
kingdom
liz truss
thank
you united kingdom is a great country
and i know that a united conservative
party can unleash the potential of all
the people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver and deliver for the
british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm the candidate with a clear vision
for the future who can drive change and
get things done
as trade secretary i negotiated deals
with allies like australia and japan
creating opportunities around the world
for british business and as prime
minister i will continue to deliver on
the opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government committed to
core conservative principles
low taxes a firm grip on spending
driving growth in the economy and giving
people the opportunity to achieve
anything they want to achieve regardless
of their background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in a government that puts more
money in your pocket and secures a
better life for you and your family
i've consistently delivered when i have
said i would
and i love our country
i want the best for us all and i'm the
person to deliver that
please welcome liz trust
hello friends it's fantastic to be here
in wales this evening
now i was brought up
in paisley in scotland
and in leeds in yorkshire so i consider
myself to be a child of the union
but i've learned many things here in
wales
i've learned in particular how to share
a sheep at the royal well show
and what i've also done
as a cabinet minister is fought for the
interests of wales
as trade secretary i got the tariffs
removed
on the airbus wings produced in
broughton
helping secure jobs for the future in
the uk's largest manufacturing factory
and after 25 years
of british lamb being banned in the
united states
i got the lamb ban lifted
and my friends
i
in september last year
raised the issue specifically
in the white house with president joe
biden
and straight after raising the issue
the ban got lifted and that is what i am
prepared to do on behalf of our country
because i care about every part of the
united kingdom i want people to have
opportunities i want people to be
successful
and i believe we can be an aspiration
nation
whichever
background you're from whichever parts
of our great nation you're from
you should have the opportunity to
succeed
but the reality is we face difficult
times at the moment
we've got the economic crisis following
covert we've got the appalling war
being prosecuted by vladimir putin in
ukraine
now is not the time for business as
usual
we need to do things differently
we need to be bold
and that is what i would do
i'd have a plan to get the growth rate
in our economy up first of all by
getting rid of all the eu laws still in
our statute books by the end of 2023
rules on
rules on procurement rules on investment
because i want to unleash
enterprise and opportunity
i'd reverse the national insurance rise
that was put in earlier this year
because i thought it was wrong to put on
taxes on ordinary people when we didn't
have to
i'd also have a temporary moratorium on
the green energy levy to cut people's
fuel bills from day one
i'd also keep corporation tax low
so we can attract investment into our
economy and we know how important
investment is into wales in the
pharmaceutical industry in the aerospace
industry right across the welsh economy
because i think having the same
corporation tax rate as france and being
10 points ahead of ireland is not going
to help us grow the economy
but we need to do more
we need to help level up our country
and you know
that there are parts of wales where it's
very difficult to get a mobile phone
signal it's very difficult to get
broadband it's difficult to get on a
train that goes anywhere very fast and
in particular north wales has been left
behind
and what i want to do is change the
treasury funding formula
so we don't put all the investment in
areas that already have it
we put the investment into places that
have been left behind and need that help
and need that economic growth i'd also
set up low tax investment zones to
attract investment into this area
i'd back our farmers
and i'm delighted to have the support of
the nfu president myrick raymond and we
worked very well together when you were
a nephew president and i was deaf for a
secretary
and i want to see
our fields full of crops and livestock i
don't want to see them full of solar
panels and other paraphernalia we have a
food security issue in britain and we
need to make sure our farmers are
farming
not filling in forms and doing red tape
and as well
as well as boosting our economy
we need to stand up to vladimir putin in
his appalling war in ukraine
i'm proud that we were the first country
to send weapons to ukraine in europe
i'm proud that we have put tougher
sanctions on russia than any other
country in the world but we need to do
more the fact is the western world was
caught napping whilst vladimir putin was
advancing
that's why we need to increase our
defense spending to three percent by the
end of the decade
and of course of course i don't need to
tell this audience that that will have
huge benefits for the defense industry
here in wales we also need to stop the
small boats and the illegal immigration
in the english channel
i i worked with pretty patel on the
rwanda policy i want to extend that to
more countries and i will make sure in
the british bill of rights we are
legislating so we can't be overruled by
the echr
but as well as freedom and democracy
overseas
we also need freedom and democracy here
in britain
and i'm a plain talking yorkshire woman
and i know that a woman
is a
woman
now
now some of you some of you might be
laughing but there are parts of
whitehall and there are parts of our
public sector that don't seem to
understand that
and i will make sure that single-sex
spaces like domestic violence shelters
are protected
i will also
i will also make sure
that we do everything we can
to defend our country and our values and
promote
our great role in the world
the fact is that there are too many
people in this country who are ashamed
of our history who talk our country down
who say the best days are behind us they
are completely wrong
i'm afraid one of them
is mark drakeford
and his his
you know
whether it's whether it's stopping the
m4 relief road whether it's whacking
attacks on our tourist industry
i will crack down on his negativity
about
wales and about the united kingdom
i joined the conservative party back in
1996
and i've been a conservative activist
i've been a councillor i've been a
constituency chairman and i know how
hard it is to win seats and we did a
brilliant job you did a brilliant job of
winning all those new seats in 2019 that
we had never had before
but you all know that we need to deliver
because we promise great things to
people in 2019 we promised a great
future we promised leveling up people
didn't vote conservative because they
wanted labor policies they voted
conservative because they wanted more
enterprise they wanted more opportunity
they wanted personal responsibility they
wanted control over their own futures
and that is what i will deliver
i'm somebody that's delivered in
government whether it's the trade deals
i did at the department of trade whether
it's the northern ireland protocol bill
that i put through the common stage of
parliament in the foreign office i'm
prepared to take on the orthodoxy even
when it might not be popular with parts
of the establishment or the civil
service i get things done
and i think that's what our voters want
and with that
with delivering for people on the ground
for making a real difference to people's
lives we will be able to take on the
plastic patriot secure stamina
and we will be able to take on
the low energy version of jeremy corbyn
that is mark drakeford
and we will win
we will win my friends
we will win the election in 2024 and we
will win the election in 2026. thank you
thank you
okay um it's my turn um so please uh
join me in welcoming back uh for the
first of the interview sections of this
evening rishi sunak
right
tax
let's go straight into it shall we um
it's been a bit of a confused picture um
you went from no tax cuts to some tax
cuts but not for some time do you accept
that you could have been a bit clearer
about what you want to do no because i
think there's two separate things going
on here and my position is is i think
consistent clear and as i said in my
speech honest now
i think the response to dealing with
inflation right now is for us to be
careful i don't think launching on a
spree of unfunded promises costing tens
and tens of billions of pounds is
is a sensible thing to do i think it
risks making the situation worse
risking it lasting far longer but also
it just means as i said all we're doing
when we do that is putting lots of
borrowing on the country's credit card
we're asking our kids and our grandkids
to pick up the tab so i don't think
that's right i don't think that's fair
what i do want to do on tax is the
following
over time i want to make sure that we
deliver a lower tax economy and i've set
out a plan to cut the basic rate of
income tax consistently over time
because i believe in hard work as does
everyone here it's a value that we all
dear it should be rewarded and that's
why i want to cut income tax and this
autumn i want to reform the corporate
tax system i don't want to stick with
the policies of the past that haven't
worked i want to change what we do cut
taxes for businesses that invest and
innovate because that's how you're going
to drive growth in a modern economy so
that's my tax plan i think it's the
right one for the country because it
will deliver jobs it will deliver growth
and ensure that we can bring prosperity
and opportunity to people everywhere
here in wales and across the united
kingdom
there's been some um there's been some
quite dire polls out um for you over the
last couple of days and with that in
mind and considering tax again will you
abolish inheritance tax
no that's that's not what i've set out a
plan to do i've set our plan to
consistently cut income tax over time
because i want to reward her reward hard
work but look i very much as you've
heard from my early remarks i'm someone
who believes in supporting aspiration i
think that is a conservative value that
many of us in this room will hold dear
and inheritance tax is a way to do that
so over time is that something that we
should look at of course we should
because people who are working hard
should be rewarded for that and if they
want to build something and leave that
for their family that's an entirely
conservative instinct and a government
that i'm privileged to lead would very
much want to support that instinct
that's what conservative prime minister
should do okay so not ruling it out but
not necessarily pledging it right now
okay understood um on the the public
sector pay
um saga that's that's well i'll of
course bring up with liz trust in a bit
she's apparently had a change of heart
on on regional paper boards for public
sector pay do you accept her
clarification
well i'll let liz speak for herself i'm
glad she you turned on that policy
because i didn't think it was the right
one and it would have meant i think
potentially you know almost half a
million workers in wales getting a pay
cut which i i don't think is is the
right policy to pursue i think you level
up by spreading opportunity around by
creating things like free ports jobs and
prosperity by cutting people's income
tax that's how i'd like to do it i don't
think cutting the pay of hundreds of
thousands of workers here and indeed
across the regions of the united kingdom
is a conservative policy that we should
adopt and i'm glad that she's changed
her mind so it was a mistake on her part
and well i think you can ask her when
she's here but to answer for her own
policies but i'm glad she's changed her
mind and you would still consider having
her in your cabinet then even though
there's been this uh mistake over the
last couple of days yes
okay
um on to the prevent program um which i
know you've been talking about um today
you've talked about it tackling islamist
extremism as the biggest threat what
about far-right extremism is that not
important as well it is but if you look
at
what our
counter-terrorist organizations are
spending the vast majority of their time
on and indeed you look at what's
happening in the criminal justice system
the overwhelming majority of it
is islamist extremism actually from
memory of something like three quarters
of all that activity is islamist
extremism so
of course that's right the prevent
program though i think at the moment was
referring a far smaller proportion of
cases on islamist extremism that balance
is probably not right and needs to be
looked at of course far-right extremism
is important and we should tackle it but
it's just nowhere near as pervasive as
the threat from islamist extremism
that's based on the evidence that we
have today i want to push you on the the
language that you've used around this
you said you want to take action against
um those who vilify britain does that
include those who just disagree with the
people who are leading britain no and
actually from the counter-terrorist unit
they've been very clear on this this is
not this is not a legal this is not a
law against that because of course there
are free speech
elements of it what this is is guidance
to all the people involved in the
prevent programme so they know what to
look for and that's based on the
evidence of how we root out terrorism in
this country and it's right that we call
out those who are trying to undermine
undermine the values of our society and
islamist extremism is a big part of that
and it's absolutely right that the
government is tough on it and a
government that i am privileged to lead
will be tough on it because that's how
we're going to keep everyone safe okay
um
we are of course in wales in cardiff the
welsh capital congratulations on your
northwest laugh when you first came on
um
i don't know if you've holidayed in
wales before spent much time in wales
before but what do you think of when you
think of wales what does it mean to you
i think of my dear friend and pps craig
williams who's sitting over there right
there and craig do you think my
pronunciation improved since we did it
at a welsh conference
okay good right um look now i'm
enormously ambitious for for wales and
you know when i look at wales i just see
the incredible potential that it has and
when we talk about you talk about
leveling up you talk about opportunity
and i'm so excited and i talked about
free ports you know that's a policy
which i know can be transformational it
can bring jobs and investment it can
catalyze new industries like nuclear in
north wales you know that that's
something that's going to be incredibly
special and we as a conservative
government conservative party can
deliver that kind of opportunity and
wales can do that for the uk economy i
talked about farming you know i
represent a very rural constituency in
north yorkshire that's my home now i do
love yorkshire lamb so i have to be a
bit careful but you know i have to
accept that welsh lamb is incredibly
popular uh well i you know i have to go
home tonight as well so be careful um
but look no but that's an incredible
opportunity for welsh farming for welsh
produce to be on kitchen tables not just
in the united kingdom but across the
world and so that's what i see when i
see wells i just see a country which has
got enormous potential and i want to
help work with everyone here to deliver
that and actually make sure that people
in wales get the public services that
they demand and that's where we need to
be more prepared to call out the
failures of the devolved government here
because this path of onward devolution
has not worked in actually delivering
better healthcare and education for the
people of wales and that's what we need
to fix well on that point then you
you've said um in your opening speech as
well that and i think you said your
government would be the most active in
wales in history i mean it sounds like
an invasion what does it mean
no it means demonstrating the benefit of
the united kingdom government in wales
and local communities and as chancellor
i was really pleased to help create
something called the leveling up fund
which meant that for the first time the
uk government could work with local
communities here in wales with local
councils and groups to figure out how to
fund projects that will help communities
and do that in a way that spreads
opportunity make sure people have pride
in the places that they call home and
for the first time doing that that
totally changed the conversation on the
ground and it meant that people had a
very clear direct line of sight to what
the uk government was doing for them but
i also said i want to be active by
holding the welsh government to account
right if i'm fortunate to be prime
minister i'm prime minister for the
entire united kingdom for every single
person and i want the people in wales to
be able to rely on the public services
that they deserve and if the uk
government is sending billions of pounds
over to wales and it's being squandered
it's not being spent properly and
children are not being taught properly
in schools and people are waiting
unacceptably long for health care
treatment we need to call that out and
we need to make sure that we improve it
because that's what the people of wales
deserve and speaking also about public
services in wales
um
hs2
um
arguably benefits england but obviously
benefits england but arguably leaves
south wales at a competitive
disadvantage
would you compensate wales with perhaps
an increased financial settlement then
to invest in the real network here well
look i'm very keen to keep investing in
infrastructure in wales and i think
you've seen from my track record it's
not just a leveling up fund but across
the country almost a dozen new projects
have been funded at an early stage to
restore railways that have been closed
down and as chancellor i was proud to
fund upgrade and signaling to the
cambrian line and improve connectivity
and the speed between swansea and
cardiff amongst other places so look
i've got a record of continuing to
deliver infrastructure in wales of
course i want to do that because that's
one of the ways that we spread
opportunity around it's how we create
jobs for people and higher wages and
that's the type of thing we should be
doing but you talked about being
activist that's why i'm going to call
out the welsh government for this absurd
policy of not building any more roads i
mean how is that going to spread any
opportunity of course it's not and i
want to be activist and call that out
and try and fix it
and on the climate and and wellbeing the
well-being of future generations uh act
has been uh in wales since 2015 would
you support um efforts to to replicate
that across the rest of the uk sorry the
well-being of future generations act
which is there are there are seven
well-being goals which is basically an
attempt to try and combat poverty and
insist that all companies in the public
sector private sector as well have what
public sector predominantly have to
actually uh live up to these
goals in order to ensure future
generations well-being right well i i
don't know the details of the act in in
in uh specifically but i mean look that
doesn't sound like the right way to do
it i think the right way to do it is to
spread opportunity and reduce poverty by
providing a brilliant education for all
our children in the first instance
[Applause]
dig into the detail of the acts as well
um a couple of quick fire questions for
you how would your friends describe you
in three words
uh
loyal honest and
hardworking
what makes you nervous
mobile
well i was what i was going to say yes
no
interviews i do plenty of
probably probably probably my wife and
my two kids
um and boris johnson may not have been
trusted
but he was certainly liked still is
why should people like you
why should people like me well look
people can make their own judgments on
me based on my actions over the past
couple of years right and you know i'm
i'm wanting to be everyone here's prime
minister leader of the party to run this
country and right now our country faces
some challenges everyone knows that and
we need to make sure that the person we
select is someone who's up to that job
and as chancellor everyone saw me act in
in very difficult circumstances to
protect probably many people here many
businesses the economy and people of
wales as well as the united kingdom and
got through a very difficult time and i
want to do that across all aspects of
government whether it's fixing the nhs
tackling the small boats in illegal
migration reforming public services
growing the economy embracing all the
exciting opportunities that we've got
ahead of us building a society that's
built on values of hard work and
aspiration and hope that's what i bring
to this job and crucially i'm the person
that can beat kierstarma in a general
election because ultimately
that's what we all need to do all the
values that we hold dear all the ideas
that we want to see in action all of
that is for naught if we don't win that
next election and i'm the person best
place to help our party do that richie
thank you very much thank you
right
we now
hand over to you so um if you can please
raise your hand i can see the gentleman
there if you just wait for um someone in
a white hoodie apparently will arrive
with a microphone and so if you could
just wait and just as i said before
please everyone keep your questions as
brief as possible um because we want to
get to as many as possible sir passion
is measured by what we say
non-passion by what we don't say and you
didn't mention to ukraine once would you
like to comment yes i'm happy to comment
in it so look i think we need to do two
things in that situation one is to
strengthen ukraine the second is to
weaken russia so as chancellor i was
proud to make sure that we found two
billion pounds from elsewhere across the
government kitty so we could send it to
ukraine and give them both the financial
support and the military support they
needed but more than that i also played
an instrumental part in weakening russia
if you think about how we are attacking
russia at the moment it's not with our
direct arms it's not through diplomacy
it's through economic sanctions those
are the sanctions that i helped put
together with finance ministers around
the world with janet yellen in the
states my colleagues in europe we went
after russian companies the russian
central bank their gold trading their
access to capital markets that's what i
did that's what i put together and as
prime minister i'll carry on with that
policy and if we can change the balance
of power by strengthening ukraine and
weakening russia we can give ukraine the
best shot of resolving that conflict to
our advantage but look on the broader
question of defense and security i was
also the chancellor that oversaw the
biggest increase in defense spending
since the end of the cold war 24 billion
pounds i prioritized the mod in the
midst of the pandemic so that they got
the funding and certainty they needed
when they were putting together their
integrated review
and i'm not going to stand here as i
know others would and tell you well i'm
going to spend this percent on defense
because i don't believe in arbitrary
targets when it comes thing comes to
something as important as our security i
take a threat based approach to that
question so what i can commit to is the
following i will invest whatever it
takes to keep all of you and everyone
else in our country safe because that is
the first duty of the prime minister and
it's certainly the first duty of a
conservative prime minister
this gentleman here and then the lady
behind afterwards
uh
you can probably just shout out sir
yes sorry
you and then it will be the lady behind
um
hannah i've got actually challenged for
you could you ask this same question of
liz trust please oh okay okay because
i'm not gonna get the opportunity thank
you uh rishi
it's fantastic hustling speech etc
but i've got a simple question for you
forgetting you're an opponent of liz
truss
why would you choose her to be prime
minister and leader of the party
well i think liz is a good liz is a good
friend of mine we we share the same
values that's why because at the end of
the day we're all conservatives and i
know this whole process is designed to
elicit the differences but we can't
forget the fact that we're all the same
team we're all the same members of the
same family here and
i know what liz knows that the real
opponent is not either of us the real
opponent is kierstarma and i know that
she will also give her all to making
sure that we all work together to beat
kierstarma at the next election because
that's the biggest task we all have and
if you think she's the best person to do
that so be it but i think i am but what
i can tell you is she will give her
heart and soul to making sure we do
because she knows who the real opponent
is it's not me it's not anyone else it's
kirsten and the labour party that's who
we gotta go smash
what are your proposals for cutting the
size of the cabinet office which
currently stands at
10 020
and for ensuring that civil servants
returned to their desks yes
so as uh one of the things that i am one
of the few last few things i did as
chancellor was start a process with the
pm of asking all the departments of
government to come back with a plan to
cut the number of civil servants by a
significant amount to reduce the civil
service back to levels that we saw years
ago because a coalition government
actually deserves enormous credit for
being quite tough on this and driving
out efficiencies and a few years ago
four or five years ago we slightly took
our foot off the gas and the numbers
have creeped up and together with the pm
we set out a mission for everyone to
come back and tell us how they were
going to cut the numbers so all those
things were just coming back when i when
i resigned so i'd like to carry on with
that plan and get civil service numbers
back to where they were five years ago
but how are we going to do that we're
going to do that by reforming public
services more generally because if we
all want to reduce the size of the state
which we do if we all want to reduce the
tax burden which we do we have to think
boldly and differently about public
services across the board because a
civil service alone is not going to
deliver the income tax cuts that we all
want to see we need to reform the nhs if
we're going to do that because it's the
nhs that's swallowing up more pounds of
everyone's hair and if we don't grip it
and reform it we'll never be able to get
the tax burden down and that's why i
want to be bold and radical on that
which is why i set out a plan to tackle
this issue of missed appointments
because for too long millions and
millions of hospital and gp appointments
go missed and that's a waste and it's
not wrong and people are abusing the
system so if we can try and change that
change behavior be tough on those make
sure that people cancel those
appointments in advance do you know what
we've done we've just created tons more
health care we can get the backlogs down
faster and it won't have cost anyone
here a penny more in money or taxes so
that's the kind of radical thinking we
need not just on civil service numbers
but across the public services and i
will bring that different type of
thinking because i want to get the tax
burden down i want to get the size of
the state down and i've got a plan to
deliver it for you
i'm sorry
did that answer your question
oh it's just one question i'm sorry we
just need to get to so there's so many
other people with their hands up
apologies and perhaps you can get your
question um to rishi afterwards and the
gentleman here in the in the lovely
jacket
thank you
i don't know can you hear me all right
yes um i'm delighted you've got uh you
say you have a strategy to tackle the
uh the small boats coming across the
channel which is getting completely out
of hand
uh can you be more specific can you tell
us exactly what it is that you're gonna
do and what's going to be different yes
i can so look in in in long form there's
on my website there's a 10 point plan
there's a video so if you've got five
minutes if you care about this issue
tonight please go home and have a look
i'll give you a couple of elements of it
now one is we need to move away from the
echr definition of asylum right it is
yes you're right we should clap that
because it's important right it is far
too broad and allows lefty lawyers to
exploit it and frustrate our efforts so
i think we should move to the refugee
convention which is another
international legal standard but it is
narrower and tighter and give will give
us a greater ability to say to people
you can't stay another thing we need to
do again thinking radically and
differently is join up our foreign
policy because at the moment we have
this slightly absurd situation that
we'll go and talk to a country about
signing a trade deal with them and
giving them access to our market we'll
even go further and say actually here's
some aid from our aid budget to help you
and whilst we're doing all of that we
slightly neglect to say oh hang on can
you take back your failed asylum seekers
that doesn't sound right does it so we
need to join up our foreign policy so
that these countries that we're doing
other things with have to agree to take
back their failed asylum seekers but go
look at the plan in a nutshell though i
am prepared to do whatever it takes
legal changes as required to get the
rwanda policy working to get control of
the situation i believe my plan will do
it i will deliver it for you because yes
we're a compassionate country we welcome
people like my family but we did that
fairly and legally and it's right that
everyone does that way we must have
control of our borders and that's what
i'm going to deliver
i'm working my way around the room and
i'd like to come to the lady here second
row back
um with a dark pair if you might yes
yeah if you mind standing up please
thank you so we can tackle inflation by
constraining demand or increasing supply
so what would you do to increase supply
renewable energy so we can
bring down cost of energy will you be
bold enough to scrap the embargo of wind
onshore wind in england
so
yes in in a nutshell we've already said
that we are open to do that where we can
do it with local communities right now
that has proven difficult but i think
actually with the different economic
incentives it might be possible that we
can get that to work we also ditto could
look at that with fracking by the way so
that's another thing where again if we
can do it with local communities we
should look at it but we can do a couple
of other things i talked about the free
ports i want to bring to wales the first
one that we set up in t-side offshore
wind manufacturing is going gangbusters
ge investing there and creating jobs
because that's a growth industry for us
if we can crack small modular reactors
north wales is a place where you could
do that alongside the big plants that's
how we'll increase homegrown supply of
energy but we can also do something else
in the short term
we can make sure that we insulate homes
better because there's a lot of
government money and it's not well spent
at the moment and if we can help people
with their loft insulation their cavity
wall insulation temperature controls
relatively simple things that don't take
very long that don't cost a fortune we
can actually save people 300 quid off
their energy bills and improve our
energy security by reducing demand but
i'll do one other thing on the supply
side while you're asking yes we need to
increase the supply of energy but
there's another area of our economy
where we're tight and that's the labor
market and right now it is unacceptable
that there are more people claiming
unemployment benefit than there are job
vacancies in the economy right that
can't be right there are more now than
there were before covid so we've got to
look at our welfare system make sure
that it's working properly and be a bit
more courageous and conservative about
saying hang on when there are all these
jobs available it can't be right for
people to be sitting at home claiming
unemployment benefit i'm prepared to be
tougher on those things to support those
people into work because that increases
the supply of labor it will be good for
them good for their families good for
the taxpayer and good for the economy so
it's not just energy we need to tackle
it's the labor market and lots of other
things but i'm confident that with my
plan we can do that beat inflation and
if we don't do that and we follow some
other plans i'm worried that the
situation will last far longer and be
far worse and i don't want that to
happen to anyone in our country a
gentleman with a blue shirt you would
stand up please and just wait for the
microphone thank you
hi hi rishi hi um welsh conservatives
have been in opposition in the centers
for nearly 25 years how are we all going
to work together to kick out these core
banisters and get into government so we
can have a welsh conservative government
in cardiff working hand in hand with the
conservative government in london yeah
yeah wow
well but
i tell you
you know hannah mentioned i want to be
an activist prime minister when it comes
to wales we need to call out devolution
for failing when it's failing as we
talked about the welsh government are
letting down people in wales with
schools that are underfunded right what
do we have in wales we have we have a
stagnant economy we have
spiraling waiting lists in the nhs and
we have chronically underfunded schools
which are depriving people of a life of
aspiration and hope right the answer to
that question is not more devolution the
answer to that question is calling out
the labor government for what they're
doing and having the uk government do
more right so that's how we're going to
start changing that we're going to start
calling it out we're going to start
holding them accountable we're going to
be a more active presence in wales
delivering for people that's how i think
we can work together to solve this
problem and the good news is you guys
have already made an incredible start
right if you look at the law i know the
local elections were difficult but that
was because of what was going on
elsewhere you know when you guys in the
last couple of elections you have
absolutely smashed it look at all the
new colleagues we have in this room that
weren't here that many years ago we can
build on that momentum that you have
created working properly with a
government in the uk bit that is
supporting you that's backing you that's
doing interesting and creative things
and the most important thing we have to
do in all of that i'm going to do
everything i can to support you but
we're going to listen to that man there
because he knows what he's doing he's
got a plan and i'd be delighted to work
with him and back him thank you andrew
i've only got um time for three more
hopefully but the lady there um with the
patterned
dress or top on
rishi both yourself and liz have spoken
about pensions and poverty
uh you're the chancellor liz was the
minister for uh women and uh equality
and then we have teresa coffey who was
pensions
as we stand now
we have the
1995 pension act on the 2011 that
impacted 3.8 million women
where their pension was extended by
maximum six years
many meetings the last meeting big
meeting where it was with the ombudsman
i'm getting there it's crucial because
there's some numbers for rishi might not
know the detail the ombudsman last july
the 20th
determined that the department of
pensions had actually
given mal administration on several
counts
if you're aware of that
we've lost a year now with any action
being taken for these 3.8 million women
at which 220 000 have already died so if
you become pm
will you put that on your list of to do
to fix
this major long-standing issue
for the women
thank you
right madam are you talking about the
waspi situation
right
fine
so look i i'm i'm going to be straight
with you i i can't promise you that i'm
going to resolve that situation yeah no
and so i just want to be straight with
you about that it has been through all
the procedures that you're familiar with
and and i've been part of a government
that signed off on all of those as
chancellor i did i can't promise you i'm
going to suddenly radically change my
mind on those and i know that's not the
answer you want but i'd rather be honest
with you but what i can tell you is that
i absolutely believe that pensioners
should have dignity in retirement that
we should support them that's why with
the cost of living that i know is tricky
for pensioners they're most affected by
cold weather we know that from a health
perspective and they don't have the
means to increase their incomes as
easily that's why part of the support i
announced as chancellor was particularly
targeted at pensioners who will receive
up to an extra 300 pounds alongside
their winter fuel payment this winter to
help and it's why the triple lock will
be back in action as required as
expected because that's what
conservative governments do we need to
look after our pensioners you've done an
enormous amount for our economy and our
society and i want to make sure that you
get the support you need going forward
um we're going to have to move on very
quickly uh if you could just a brief
question please sir yes certainly first
of all rishi many congratulations on
introducing and eating the incredibly
bold and brave furlough scheme and it
was superb thank you
secondly and
andrew
andrew stevenson
introduced the debate tonight saying the
one key thing is winning the next
general election my question is to rishi
how do you feel when
the latest ipsos mori poll looking at
the public says that 35 of people in the
general public believe you have what it
takes to be a good prime minister but
only 24 percent believe liz is uh
capable of that and yet the few and you
have the overwhelming support of
conservative mps we've seen that before
but the future
of the next prime minister leading the
next election is to be decided by only
.3
of the electorate
with an average age somewhere between 65
and 70. thank you
right well
thank you i think
um for
highlighting the stats very helpful um
look
you know everyone in this room you you
guys are going to take this really
seriously because you all know you have
a really important responsibility
because we're not in opposition we're in
government and whoever you select is
going to be prime minister day one right
you all know the challenges that our
country faces at the moment whether it's
with our public services with getting
our economy growing helping people
through this inflation challenge and the
cost of living you know what sits on the
in tray that's what you're choosing
someone who can grip all those things
from day one but you're also picking
someone who can then go and win that
next election because as i said that is
the most important thing and i know all
of you will take that responsibility
incredibly seriously and actually where
i'm going around the country people are
also saying to me that they're talking
to their friends their family the people
they're out and about with who are not
necessarily members because they get
that they're doing this and all of you
are doing this on behalf of the country
we have to provide a leader that can
lead the entire country and win that
next election so i'd urge you all to do
the same thing right because yes we are
a small group of people but i know you
will talk to your friends who are family
who are not necessarily members you'll
stop people in your communities get
their view see who they think would make
the right prime minister for this time
as well i'm confident that when you ask
people that question
they will say to you that i am the best
person to lead this country at this time
to build a society based on hope and
hard work and aspiration and the best
person to take it to kiestarma at the
next election and smash him and make
sure labour are not in power for another
generation
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed thank you
thank you
now um while we await the second
contender obviously liz trust i just
want to remind you all thank you all so
much for those really thoughtful
questions and i i know that some of
these questions are hugely emotional and
important and i'm sure that the the
conservative team around here will be
able to take note of your questions and
get them to the the candidates as well
and get them to the to the teams if you
want to um have a more thorough answer
shall we say we're just so restricted
with time but thank you so much um now
let's uh get to the uh second contender
to be leader of the conservative party
and the next prime minister please
everyone join me in welcoming liz truss
don't trip up in the heels
good to see you liz thank you please
have a seat um so we'll kick off on um
public sector hey
um just to clear things up because i
know it's something you've been talking
about non-stop probably for the last 36
48 hours or so and so regional pay for
public sector workers you said initially
it was willful misrepresentation
was it actually a woeful mistake on your
part
well what what happened was we announced
the policy it was misinterpreted it was
never intended by the media it was never
intended to apply to nurses doctors and
teachers so i wanted to clear the matter
up straight away
and i have been very clear we're now not
going ahead with that policy it wasn't a
central part of my policy platform and
i've been clear that it is not happening
there will be no regional pay boards
it was going to be 8.8 billion pounds
that was your projected saving from that
policy um when it was first announced
where will that money come from now
as i've said this is not part of my
central costings the central costings i
have put forward are the reduction
in national insurance
keeping corporation tax low
and also having a temporary moratorium
on the green levy those policies will
cost roughly 30 billion pounds
and
they will be funded out of general
taxation and will still be able to see
the debt falling after
three years now the policy you're
referring to was something that was much
longer term it wasn't about the
immediate term but as i've said we're
not going ahead with it it's not
happening
and i've been very clear about that and
i'm somebody
who when things are misinterpreted when
mistakes are made i'm honest about that
and i've said we're not doing it the
policy as i understand it was initially
introduced to boost private sector and
competitiveness i mean wales is the most
public sector dependent part of the uk
arguably it would be a good thing would
it not to introduce look the way i want
to
increase wales's competitiveness is
attract more investment into wales
that's why i believe in keeping
corporation tax low that's why i'd set
up low tax investment zones and that's
why i've been focused when i've been at
the trade department on cutting tariffs
on welsh goods getting
more products into international markets
and boosting opportunity in that way
you've said um
many times through the course of this
campaign so far that you want to cut
taxes to promote growth without fuelling
any inflation we could get an
announcement from the bank of england
tomorrow about uh borrowing rates going
up um so does that change your your
perspective or change your policy plans
we need to look at what's caused
inflation inflation has been caused by a
huge supply-side shock after covid and
the appalling war that vladimir putin
has perpetrated in ukraine and the tax
measures that i'm putting in
i.e reducing national insurance
keeping corporation tax low will
actually help increase supply in the
economy so they won't fuel inflation
quite the opposite they'll make sure
more goods and services are available
the best way of dealing with inflation
is monetary policy and what i've said is
i want to change the bank of england's
mandate to make sure
in the future it matches some of the
most effective central banks in the
world at controlling inflation the last
time the mandate was looked at was in
1997 under gordon brown things are very
very different now so i think the best
way of controlling inflation is monetary
policy but what is simply wrong at this
time is to be putting taxes up on
ordinary people when they're struggling
to pay their fuel bills they're
struggling to pay their food bills and
you know
increa reducing a tax that was increased
in april is not inflationary it is
helping people with everyday costs
various pay review bodies have proposed
an uh increased public sector payless
across the nhs teachers police etc and
in order for the welsh center to deliver
on that they would presumably need more
money here so would you increase the
financial settlement to wales well there
are consequentials through the barnet
formula that deliver for wales and it's
important that
that is followed through on but of
course the national health service is
under the welsh government and that's
the right that's the right way of
organizing things but would you increa
increase the funding a lot well it
automatically follows through the barnet
formula when extra money is allocated in
england it follows through to wales okay
so that's a yes well it's it's automatic
um
we're in wales what does wales mean to
you do you have you visited wales much
what do you think of when you think of
wales
well first of all i think of the
fantastic food and as you might have
heard earlier i'm a huge fan of welsh
lamb
and welsh beef and the fantastic feed
that's produced
right across wales i've been on holiday
to wales a lot
horse riding outward bound all that kind
of thing
beach holidays as well and it's a
it's a great it's a great part of the
united kingdom and i guess i think of
you know all the famous people from
wales like shirley bassey
who i'm a huge fan of one of my favorite
songs is goldfinger
i love i love the james bond theme tubes
very good i'm not going to ask you to
name welsh rugby players i thought you
were going to ask me to sing goldfinger
would welcome a rendition of course they
would but no no we won't some people
have heard it
um you've already spoken about uh
mark drakeford and would you ignore him
in the same manner that you intend to
ignore nicolas sturgeon i think it's a
very different situation in scotland and
wales because what's happening in
scotland is the entire resources of the
scottish government are being used to
run essentially an independence campaign
and i think that is grossly
irresponsible
the scottish government are not
delivering for the people of scotland
they are simply spending their time and
nicola sturgeon is spending her time
agitating for independence and the point
i was making is the uk government should
be
doing what we're doing which is
delivering for the people of scotland
you know whether that's driving jobs and
investment in scotland whether it's
delivering a strong foreign policy and
defence policy that protects the entire
united kingdom that's what we should be
doing in scotland i think the issue
in wales is different you know the
problem we've got in wales and i
mentioned mark drakeford earlier
is that you know the opportunities that
are being brought forward by the uk
government are not being taken up like
the m4 relief road which would actually
generate new jobs and growth here in
wales or
you know or
you know the fact you know i've made it
very clear i don't like taxes very much
and the fact that he wants to put a tax
on tourism in wales i think is
a very big problem just as we are trying
to recover the economy after covert and
what i would do is i would want to work
with andrew arty davis and the team at
the center to make sure that together we
have a very strong plan
to challenge drakeford's record in wales
and labour has been in power for 20
years
but also to challenge what labour are
doing across the united kingdom and what
kierstarma is doing and i would want to
have regular meetings with andrew and
his team i'd want to involve our welsh
colleagues
members of the senate in work that we do
at westminster so we are really
making sure that we are putting the best
possible case to the welsh people and
you know andrew does a fantastic job of
challenging mark drakeford and i want
him to carry on doing that so just i
think i got the answer to this but just
a yes no would your government build the
m4 relief road yes okay thank you um on
to um taiwan just in with your foreign
secretary hat on please should nancy
pelosi have gone
nancy pelosi is well within her rights
as speaker of the united states congress
to
travel to taiwan the issue here
is the
language and the escalatory language
that we've heard from china and i think
that is irresponsible and i urge them to
de-escalate but should she have gone
then yes yes i said well i've said yes
she's well within her rights to go okay
i mean it's not my decision whether the
speaker of the u.s congress travels to
taiwan no of course but no presumably
you have an opinion on it so thank you
for that and i want to get to get to a
couple of quick fire questions um
how would your friends describe you in
three words
determined loyal
and fun
what makes you nervous
um i was very very nervous at the
lionesses match when
when there was 10 minutes to go and they
just
they were winning two one and i was
absolutely petrified i also don't i i
think i mentioned getting an outward
band of wells i don't like sort of
jumping over large caverns and things
like that i find that quite scary
there's one of the final questions uh to
your opponent rishi sunak was uh the
fact that it seems at least uh according
to some polls that you're very popular
within the party uh membership um but uh
the general broader british electorate
are less convinced that you would be
able to take on sakir stama and why do
you think you would be a better
candidate than rishi soon after that i
don't think that is the evidence we're
seeing in fact i think there was a
recent poll showing that i would be a
more popular prime minister than
kierstarma but the the
the reality
the reality of the situation
is that we need to prove to people who
voted for us in 2019 that we can deliver
what we promised in our 2019 manifesto
that is the issue and i'm somebody that
delivers i'm somebody that says what i
think
what you see is what you get with me i'm
not the most you know slick presenter
but i am somebody who is trusted and i
think that is important and that's what
we will be judged on at the next
election you've described yourself as
the change candidates and the hope
candidates and you've also changed your
mind quite a lot on policy over the
years lib dem to tory remain to leave
decades-old tax policy to tax cuts are
you flaky
i'm i'm somebody who i wasn't born a
conservative you know i was born into a
left-wing household you know my mother
used to take me on cnd marches in the
1980s
i
grew up i got interested in politics i
joined the liberal democrats because i
thought they believed in freedom i found
out that they didn't really and i joined
the conservative party when i was 21 and
i've been a conservative activist ever
since and you know on the subject
of the
um remain vote
yes i was unsure at the time i was
pretty much on the fence
i've always said that if we weren't part
of the european union i wouldn't want to
join it but i was concerned about some
of the disruption the fact is that
disruption didn't happen
and since the brexit vote
i've done more than most people in
government to deliver on the
opportunities of brexit whether it's the
trade deal whether it's sorting out the
northern ireland protocol whether it's
promoting
our foreign policy and being able to run
an independent sanctions regime which we
were against russia and i'm absolutely
determined now to get those eu rules off
our statute books and to really open up
britain and
just just finally i want to say on this
point
i think as somebody who is from not a
conservative background who you know
i've got friends in other parties my
family lots of them don't support the
conservatives but i know how to convince
people on how to bring people on board
so i think being a convert
is actually an asset because what do we
have to do at the election we have to
convert people we can't just talk to
ourselves we actually have to go there
and win in the country
and just finally though
my final question really there are
posters everywhere here saying um
trusted to trusted to deliver i see what
you've done there with the play on words
though even though some people wanted
that in i didn't do that um do you can
you understand why some people might be
unsure that you are
that they can trust you when you have
changed your mind so much it's arguably
a good thing to sort of when the facts
change your opinion changes that's fine
but
some people might question whether they
can trust you to to deliver on what you
say now if it might change in the future
everything i've promised to do in
politics you know i went into my job as
child care minister in the cameron
government you know i delivered the
policy on that and delivered the new
gcses my daughter's currently sitting in
the new jcsc she's not very necessarily
very happy with it but i delivered that
policy you know as environment secretary
i delivered the response to floods and i
you know worked to open up these
opportunities for farmers across the
united kingdom in trade people said we
couldn't get the trade deals done i've
done them you know yes i do
change my mind and i do change my
opinions over time but the principles
remain the same i've always believed
people should be free to live their own
lives i've always believed that people
and their families are best placed to
make decisions not big governments and
i've always believed that you know in
personal responsibility and taking
responsibility of your own life but you
know who on earth has exactly the same
views at 15 as they have at 55 i think
that's
you know that would be more weird in my
opinion
it's now time to go over to all of you
as well so if i can perhaps yes uh just
here at the front if you wouldn't mind
just standing up and waiting for um
there we go a microphone
thank you
hi liz um i have a severely autistic
brother and you said you want to cut the
national insurance rates so my question
is how would you fund social care
so what i've said is i don't want to
raise national insurance i want to put
it back to what it was before but i'm
still committed to the funding for nhs
and social care i would just pay that
out of general taxation but i would
still make sure we're paying down the
debt after three years
and my priority would be putting that
money into social care rather than into
the national health service because i
think at the moment our councils are
struggling and many people are trapped
in beds in the national health service
because there isn't the social care
available so my priority would be to put
the money into social care and of course
we need to do more to make sure that
frontline workers in the nhs are
empowered we're dealing with issues like
gp appointments and ambulance services
but my priority would be using that
money for social care to help people
like your brother
thank you um the lady here at the front
first please and then we'll go to the
gentleman at the back
hello liz hi um
during the competition there's been so
much mudslinging
whether it's shoes earrings cartoon
knives in the back or patronizing
man's playing
it's very demeaning and to manage to our
party conservatives values and ethos
what will you do to repair this damage
before the election
and will you have sufficient time to
implement your plans to convince the
wider electorate that in that short
period of time to avoid a stalmer
government
well i do agree with you
that there have been some
unfortunate sort of occurrences during
this leadership contest frankly it
wasn't a contest i wanted and i think
everybody was quite caught by surprise
when it happened
and some of the things like the debates
i wouldn't necessarily have so many
debates again
i think it's better if we're talking to
each other within the conservative party
rather than airing our dirty linen in
public so i completely 100 agree with
you on that
what what i would do as prime minister
is first of all get on with it you know
we need to start legislating whether
it's to
make sure essential services are being
provided on our railways legislating on
the tax cuts legislating to replace eu
law with new british laws we need to get
on with that straight away and i'm
somebody who does get things done in
government and i get them done quicker
what i would also do
is make sure that if i'm selected as
prime minister i appoint people in my
cabinet who are people who can be
trusted and don't spend their time
leaking and briefing i want competent
people who deliver for the people across
britain and that is what will help us
win against kierstarma
okay um at the back please
and then i'm going to be walking over
here i'm not walking but coming over
there
uh will your increase in defense
spending actually lead to an increase in
troop numbers during this time of crisis
in europe
well what i want to do
is review the integrated review
to make sure
it is tough enough on dealing with the
issues we face now particularly the
threat from russia
and also
an increasingly aggressive china
and i will review with the defense
secretary the various
parts of the armed forces as well as the
new technologies we need to invest in
like cyber and space and make sure that
we have the right balance but what's
become clear is when we face a one land
war in europe we need to look at
conventional forces as well as those
modern forces as well we can't choose
between them
okay thank you does that answer your
question yeah thank you very much um
just here please yeah in the pink shirt
i believe it is yes uh sorry there's the
gentleman behind actually sorry
my question is one about transport
if you were prime minister how would you
change the
balance and schemes between road
railways buses
pedestrian cycling and shipping
well i used to work in the shipping
industry actually liquid natural gas
shipping so i do i am fond of the
maritime industry and i do think it's
important quite a lot of the issues
around shipping are actually due to the
complex set of regulations so i think
it's not just about the public money we
spend it's also making these projects
easier to deliver i think transport
projects take too long
i was involved in a rail project in my
constituency in norfolk and it had to go
through five stages before they even got
to the point where they drew up a plan
and we've got to speed those things up
we simply can't wait to get spades in
the ground i also want to make the
funding more level across the country
but there are you know there are
different circumstances in different
parts of the country in rural areas
people tend to rely on roads obviously
very important in urban areas it's
easier to have more provision for
cycling and more provision for trains so
what i am not though is anti-car and
what i don't like at the moment about
modern britain is how anti-car some of
the local authorities and policies
around the country seem to be
and i know
i know as a rural mp
you often have to have a car to be able
to get around
um the gentleman there with his hand up
and the blue everyone's got blue
wristbands ignore me um and then to the
lady over there with the sunglasses on
her head uh sorry just there if you
could no no just
behind sorry i'm so sorry
hi um i'm just wondering because
although housing is a devolved area it's
a british marketplace so what you do
will have a great effect across every
nation
what will you do to increase supply of
housing and tackle greedy land banking
by developers and so people my age can
get on the housing ladder thank you
well first of all what i want to do on
housing finance
is to make it the case that when you
are renting for a number of years that
positive renting history counts towards
the ability to get a mortgage so it
should be easier for people who are
renting to get on the housing ladder in
terms of housing supply overall and i
recognize as a different or a separate
planning system in wales what i want to
do is get rid of the top-down targets
set by whitehall and instead have
different
systems operating in different areas
because i think what we need in a place
like london where there should be more
building up uh in the city is very very
different from what we need in somewhere
like cornwall uh there are rural
businesses and rural homes that need to
be built or indeed other parts of the
country that need investment and there
i'd like to see modern boardvilles if
you like where you get
workplaces built alongside homes where
people locally working can live and i
think we could be much more creative at
the moment we've got a very rigid
planning system
it's very very cumbersome it takes years
to get everything through people get
frustrated and there's a feeling of
powerlessness
in local areas so i would fix that
thank you um yes over there please
hi um both you and rishi have said that
you would withdraw from the echr if
necessary
what do you deem
as necessary
and how long would it take and would it
leave us with complete autonomy over
illegal immigration
thank you so
i i firmly believe that we can deal with
this issue in domestic legislation
through the british bill of rights so i
think that's the best way of doing it i
also believe that
there's more we can do to reform the way
the ecr echr works but my view is that
by making the right changes to domestic
legislation we will completely be able
to run our own border policy effectively
we'll be able to run the rwanda policy
and that's the important principle for
me is being able to run that policy
successfully without what's happening at
the moment which is when uh illegal
migrants get on a plane they again then
get on their phone to the lawyer and
they're not able to we're not able to
persuade them to leave the country so
it's fixing that problem is what's
important to me
um there's a gentleman there in a dark
grey blazer who's had his hand up for
about 20 minutes so i don't want it to
fall off
thank you i am we're the party of wealth
creators innovators and
entrepreneurs
now during the covered the lockdown a
lot of those people felt excluded and
abandoned and ignored
many of them when i was campaigning in
the may elections say to me i'm not
going to vote conservative i am an
actual conservative how do we win their
votes back
well we need to we need to win those
people's votes back
and i don't think that we've done enough
to support small businesses i think in
many cases they're over regulated and
it's difficult to
get on and get things done as a small
business it's also true for farmers it's
also true for the self-employed and
there is an issue with treasury
orthodoxy that wants everybody to be
employed and has gradually made it
harder and harder to be self-employed in
the tax system i would want to review
that
along with a general look at the tax
system i'm concerned for example about
business rates and how they affect small
businesses as well so that we get a
simpler tax system that's fairer but the
fundamental principle for me
is that we have to be on the side of
people who set up and run businesses
people who are self-employed people who
go out to work every day that is who we
as conservatives should be on the side
of at every single time
that any piece of so-called proposed
regulation passes my desk i always ask
the question what would the implication
be for a business of this
because many small businesses don't have
massive tax departments and hr
departments and legal departments to do
with all this they end up filling out
the paperwork themselves so we have to
be absolutely rigorous in removing that
regulation and not allowing new stuff to
emerge
um gentlemen here if you wouldn't mind
just standing up so that people can see
you for a second we just need to get a
microphone to you
thank you
hi
i'd love to be able to ask you to sing
but i won't
um yeah quite a few crises coming down
the road at the new pm um one we haven't
talked about is the climate crisis um
rishi talked about
uh fracking could you tell us a bit more
about the green protection credentials
you'd bring to the party and how you'd
win those green votes thank you
well i i was an environmentalist before
it was fashionable i was campaigning in
the 1990s uh to protect the ozone layer
and if you remember at the time it was
margaret thatcher who led the charge on
that signing the montreal protocol and
we cannot let green issues be owned by
the left because they are fundamentally
or they're known as watermelons aren't
they greed on the outside socialist on
the
inside
anti-enterprise pro just more and more
regulation tying business down so what i
want to do is hit the net zero target
but have a temporary moratorium on the
green levy
reduce the cost for businesses and
consumers of energy use more gas in the
short term we need to do more to exploit
the north sea reserves as well as
fracking uh in areas that support it but
at the same time do more to leverage
private sector
investment into transforming our economy
because there are huge opportunities
it is good to to invest in renewable
energy and nuclear energy but we need to
do it in a way which is about unleashing
private enterprise
not
trying to regulate it out of existence
thank you the lady in the striped top uh
just in front of the pillar there please
you've got your hand up
oh sorry just there you
thank you hi um i was wondering what are
your opinions on building the seven
barrage to increase our electricity
supply considering it could be ten
percent of our current um demand but
also as you were talking about nuclear
is there an argument to nationalize the
nuclear industry to actually get it to
grow properly because we're going to
need it with when
demand could increase three to four
times in the future
i think i think the plain reality of
nuclear is that the government does have
to underwrite it at some level and i'm
willing to do that because i think it's
a vital part of our energy security i'm
strongly supportive of going ahead with
willva in anglesey and on the issue of
the barrage i know that project was
looked at before but was looked at in
times when energy prices were much lower
and we weren't facing the energy
security crisis we are now so i'd
certainly look at that project again
as prime minister to see if it stacks up
and see what we can do to make it happen
because we need a wide variety of energy
sources i talked about gas as a
transition fuel i think nuclear is
important i think renewables are
important as well so we have to do all
of it and frankly we're wasting we're
making up for lost time we should have
been investing in nuclear years ago
and we now have to get on with it very
soon and final question gentlemen there
um with the glasses on if you wouldn't
mind just
standing for your question thank you
very much and keep it brief please
thank you liz what you've just said
about the environment but it really
struck me that in your speech the only
environmental mention was actually about
scrapping the green levy
um
now
if you if you're as committed to net
zero as you as you say you are um
why is it that you're pledging to scrap
this um you know money that is really
essential to decarbonize our home to
help keep us was warm in the winter
without describing exactly what you put
in place to replace it
just please reassure environmentalists
like me that you're not just promising
net zero as a target but you will be the
person that can actually deliver it and
not take us backwards i do support net
zero but what i think is completely
wrong is that we have put this money
this tax on people's fuel bills when
fuel bills are so high we know that fuel
bills are going up
we also know
we know that the cost of this which is
four billion pounds is affordable within
our current budget envelope so i think
our priority at the moment should of
course be reaching net zero but i want
to do it in a way that unleashes private
sector investment not in a way that
punishes ordinary people who really are
struggling at the moment to pay those
fuel bills okay thank you very much liz
trust thank you lovely to see you thank
you thank you
round of applause
please i'm very very sorry to the
gentleman here i didn't get your
question in i apologize it seemed a bit
unfair to leave tonight with uh with a
kind of like why would you vote for
rishi
but thank you all very very much indeed
and for your participation and i know
that there are still vacancies for
online registration if you still need to
make up your mind and need to hear more
from the candidates um for future
hustings as well i think there's about a
dozen more to go or something like that
so plenty of opportunity to still hear
from them
if you compare it that is and thank you
so much for your company this evening
and jachinvar
and nostar everyone
[Applause]
you